die drei jungs so wie in der schweiz
ist schulbedarf christen würden die
familie hat es sich einfach so und wir
da machen finde ich hatte eine
andere sache
[Musik]
heute haben pascal und felix wolf drei
eigene kinder
wie konnten die zwei männer die natur
überlisten und wie wachsen kinder mit
zwei vätern auf davon handelt dieser
film
[Musik]
die chemie als 7 und der älteste sohn
der familie
rachel wird bald 6
[Musik]
und jonathan ist mit fünf der jüngste
nicht alle drei geschwister sind
genetisch miteinander verwandt der
älteste stammt von felix wolf ab seine
jüngeren geschwister von pascal wolf
nach amerika wo das werk sieht das aber
schwule oder familie gründen als er
braucht das man so eine agentur
geldhäuser auf der leihmutter suchen wo
es hilft ev spenderin suchen und nach
der klinik wo das alles macht und die
ganze technologie hat man es kostet viel
geld vor ihm ungefähr hundert us
wirtschaft mit allem drum und dran
traisen und sowie der bereich nochmals
macht als 150 sitzen proben
150000 dollar unmöglich zu machen was
eigentlich unmöglich ist
[Musik]
wir fragen uns ob man die biologie so
austricksen darf um sich den
kinderwunsch zu ermöglichen
was unterscheidet sich andere klassische
familie
das muss das 2 1 machen
und sie bei großen und fröhlich aus
[Musik]
was kann und felix wolf lernten sich vor
18 jahren in der schweiz kennen
felix wolf bekamen jobangebot und zog
nach new york
escape
pascal wolf folgte ihm sie kauften sich
eine wohnung in manhattan wo sie noch
heute leben
der wunsch nach eigenen kindern wäre in
der schweiz vermutlich nie aufgekommen
auch weil es der schweizer gesetz
verbietet aber hier in new york in einer
jüdischen gemeinde für homosexuelle
trafen sie das erste mal schule eltern
ihr wunsch nach einer familie war
geweckt
[Musik]
das
schönste am körper familia
mittag in zahlen sieht das so das ist
wahnsinn wie ganz befriedigt oder
smartcard mit mit der familie sieht es
musiziert das militär zu locker weil sie
weil sie sich entwickelt erwartet wenn
die sachen werden wie ihre
persönlichkeit sich ein falter das ist
ja
extrem
wir wüssten gerne wie die kinder über
die familie denken heute ist es für sie
noch kein thema aber wie gehen sie
später einmal damit um dass sie nur dank
einer konstruierten schwangerschaft auf
der welt sind die väter wollen dem thema
offen begegnen und die fragen der kinder
beantworten sobald sie sich stellen
[Musik]
um sieben uhr steht die familie auf die
kinder gehen schon alle zur schule
[Musik]
pascal wolf arbeitet als psychologe
seine praxis ist gleich neben der
wohnung
er macht jeden tag das frühstück und
bringt die kinder zur schule
felix wolf ist professor für tiermedizin
richtig zeit für die kinder hatte
eigentlich nur am wochenende
das sei schade sagte uns
weil beide väter arbeiten schaut die
nanny fabiola kuhstall ist zu den
kindern und zum haushalt zelte frau im
haushalt
und zwar aus dem grund mehrheit von
35 bis 44 kg
und sie ist sie ist einfach sehr wichtig
und sie ist
[Applaus]
roma
[Musik]
will nicht in die schule gehen seine
klassenkameraden wollten gestern nicht
mit ihm spielen
[Musik]
und nachher
dominik und du mit ihren
[Musik]
augen stürzte jeremia und die anderen
hinter kapsel werde die der schule will
sie aber nicht normal
konventionelle familie hansen 2 vater
haben ihm eigentlich schon
mehr fragen ist eigentlich
schweiz und da ich mir angst einiges
größe
von verwandten und bekannten curtis
schweiz auch doch langsam und akademisch
wikipedia bis jetzt gerade in zwei
heimen bis negativ sagt hier ist mein
geschenk die angst aber ich sie auch
immer und kanzelt worten gegangen und er
ist bis jetzt noch nie erlebt
auch diesmal wurde jeremia nicht wegen
seiner schwulen väter gehänselt er ist
nicht der einzige mit homosexuellen 11
an seiner schule
[Musik]
die nanny fabiola kostal es ist zeit die
remy us geburt bei der familie meist die
kinder von der schule ab der drei söhne
und stammt aus ecuador dank ihr wachsen
die kinder dreisprachig auf
[Musik]
was denken sie fehlt den kindern eine
mutter
das ist ein heikles thema
ich bin selber mutter von drei söhnen
und darum denke ich manchmal
fehlt eine mutterfigur
aber sie bekommen die liebe ihrer väter
und es gibt ja auch noch nicht ich bin
für sie da und ich liebe sie sie sind
teil meines lebens
[Musik]
morgen mit rachel sechs jahre alt felix
wolf becke den geburtstagskuchen
genetisch verwandt ist er mit seiner
tochter nicht sie entstand aus dem
erbgut seines ehemannes felix wolf
ertragen adoptiert
am anfang stärker das irgendwie gerät
sehr gewichtig also bei mir weil ich
wäre eigentlich inka zeit
und immer sagt das ist ja es ist schön
dass der zum beispiel
wirklich hat das ist doch schon
bald aber auf der anderen seite dass ich
jetzt für mich ist strahlend und werden
genauso mehr in das gibt es gab so kann
unter schüttelt
der schwule mit einer leihmutter und
gespendeten eizellen kinder zeugen
scheint die new york niemanden zu stören
ganz im gegensatz zur schweiz hier waren
die reaktionen auf diese konstruierte
schwangerschaft ausschließlich negativ
auch bei ihren verwandten stießen die
wolfs auf großen widerstand in zürich
besuchen wir die schwester von felix
wolf als ihr bruder erzählte dass er
vater wird löst das einen heftigen
streit aus
also es ist nicht so dass sie als
schwules paar wände familie haus und so
die idee dass alles machbar sie im leben
wenn wir nur geld investiert da kam
quasi anders erreichen und der andere
punkt ist sie das gefühl haben das läuft
auf kosten der frau
spenderin minister zeige
notlage von irgendwelchen frauen los um
so keine zu seine ziele was dank die
hügel ja ich selber wir dass es hat sich
nicht wahnsinnig viel geld das
eigentlich
würde das nicht machen für mich aber ich
hatte das akzeptieren
wir fragen uns ist man in den usa dem
land der unbegrenzten möglichkeiten
einfach unserer zeit voraus werden auch
bei uns eine schule kinder kriegen oder
ist das ein zeichen von machbarkeitswahn
zurück bei der familie wolf heute ist
rachels geburtstag wie jedes jahr macht
pascal wolf ein foto für die
eizellenspende hin von rachel
die eizellen für rachel hat kim
ellingson gespendet wir besuchen sie in
der kalifornischen hauptstadt sacramento
bei ihr zu hause
abgesehen von den jährlichen fotos die
sie bekommt weil sie nichts über das
mädchen das auf der anderen seite des
landes aufwächst
sieht so aus wie sie aussahen als sie
sechs jahre alt waren ja ich finde sie
fängt an mir ähnlich zu sehen
stolz schickt kämmerlings sind die fotos
jedes jahr an ihre eltern weiter
ich fühle mich nicht wie ihre mutter sie
ziehen sie auf und sie sind ihre eltern
sie geben ihre liebe ich habe nicht das
gefühl das ist mein kind ist
aber da ist immer noch diese aufregung
weil ich weiß dass sie ein teil von mir
ist sie ist nicht irgendein kind für
mich es ist er so ich half ihnen und sie
ist ein teil von mir es ist sehr
aufregend
sie wird die rache später gerne
kennenlernen aber als eizellen spenderin
darf sie die initiative nicht ergreifen
rachel ist nicht das einzige kind mit
ihrem erbgut mehrmals hat sie als allen
gespendet vier kinder sind daraus
entstanden bei der ersten spende war sie
28 heute ist sie 41 sie lebt mit ihrem
freund zusammen der aber die meiste zeit
weg ist er arbeitet für die armee in
afghanistan
eigene kinder haben sie nicht
[Musik]
pascal und felix wolf haben links sind
anhand ihres fotos und eines
ausführlichen steckbrief es ausgesuchte
allen spenderinnen sind in einem katalog
aufgeführt mit allen angaben zu
erbkrankheiten ausbildung und
gesundheitszustand
tellings sind musste sich für jede
einzelne spende einen monat lang hormone
spritzen damit sie statt nur einem
gleich mehrere dutzend eier auf smart
produziert die eier wurden am ende
dieses monats bei einer operation
entnommen mit den spermien befruchtet
und der leihmutter eingesetzt für die
eizellenspende bekam sie rund 6000
dollar aber des geldes wegen habe sie es
nicht gemacht
ich erinnere mich dass ich darüber in
einem magazin gelesen habe dass ich
dachte dass ich etwas gutes
etwas gutes das ich tun kann
ich brauchte meine eier nicht also kann
ich jemand anderem helfen der sie
brauchen kann
ich weiß nicht wieso ich nie kinder
wollte aber ich wusste bereits in frühen
jahren dass ich keine kinder will
und das war eine gute art anderen zu
helfen und um meine guten gene zu nutzen
[Gelächter]
mit guten genen anderen helfen das
klingt gut aber ist es wirklich nur ein
selbstloser dienst fragen wir uns mit
rache lebt ein teil von kingson weiter
ohne dass sie sich je um sie kümmern
musste
[Applaus]
heute vor sechs jahren kam rache zur
welt bis zur geburt worten gefährte das
geschlecht des kindes nicht wissen als
sie erfuhren dass sie eine tochter
bekommen hatten die fette bedenken einem
mädchen nicht gewachsen zu sein aber
schnell waren diese bedenken verflogen
dieses bündel
woge zu schlafen
jeweils drei tage nach der geburt
verließen die fete mit dem baby das
spital
[Musik]
ja
auf den heutigen besuch freut sich die
ganze familie die frau die alle drei
kinder zur welt gebracht hat kommt zu
besuch
[Musik]
die leihmutter anschlug wurde zu einer
engen freundin mehrmals pro jahr besucht
zusammen mit ihrem mann die familie wolf
in new york
[Musik]
sie ist 34 jahre alt lebt in texas und
hat acht kinder zur welt gebracht drei
eigene 3 für felix und pascal wolf
danach nochmals zwei kinder für hetero
paare
ich liebe es schwanger zu sein ich weiß
viele frauen haben eine harte zeit aber
ich habe das glück einfacher
schwangerschaften zu haben ich fühle
mich großartig und ich erhole mich
schnell
angela muth gebar alle kinder ohne
kaiserschnitt die geburten seien sehr
schnell und ohne komplikationen
verlaufen aber auch wenn alles gut geht
wie kann eine frau neun monate lang ein
kind in sich tragen und es dann einfach
weggeben sie beantwortet unsere frage
mit einem vergleich
wenn meine nachbarin an meine tür kommt
mit einem halb gebackenen kuchen und
sagt mein ofen gehen kaputt kann ich
deinen benutzen dann lasse ich sie man
den ofen benutzen dann ist der kuchen
immer noch der ire und sie hat nur man
den ofen gewinn das ist genau das
gleiche szenario das baby gehört mir
nicht ich bin eher der langzeit
babysitter dann gebe ich es den
richtigen eltern zurück egal ob das eine
mutter und ein vater oder zwei väter
sind
ihr mann mit dem speziellen nebenerwerb
von anfang an einverstanden
25.000 dollar bekam angelo
schwangerschaft aber sie habe es nicht
wegen des geldes gemacht wie ihr mann
arbeitet sie bei einer bank
sie will anderen menschen das glück
einer eigenen familie ermöglichen
ethische bedenken hat sie keinen
es gibt leute die sagen wenn sie selber
nicht schwanger werden können dann hat
es bestimmt seine gründe ich finde aber
wir haben die technologie
und wenn wir es nicht machen sollten
dann hätten wir die technologie nicht
darum ein ich hatte nie bedenken
im vergangenen jahr gewann sie das
letzte mal für ein fremdes paar ein kind
ein neuntes mal schwanger werden das
will sie nicht nur für felix und pascal
wolf würde sie eine ausnahme machen doch
deren familienplanung scheint
abgeschlossen
aber wenigstens zwei
mindestens 23 nach dem
dramatischen 4
und so endet dieser film bei drei
kindern die nur dank moderner
technologie und eines raffinierten
teamworx überhaupt auf der welt sind bei
aller skepsis und allen vorbehalten
eines ist sicher ihre mia rachen und
jonathan sind wunschkinder
[Musik]